- I heard that you had a performance
'cause you liked the Beatles.
Was there a "Yellow Submarine"
performance or maybe-
- I was in first grade and
there was a talent show
in Long Beach, California,
Tincher Elementary School
and I sang the "Yellow Submarine".
And I had this thing I would do
to make my family members
and friends laugh.
It was called the helium voice.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And when I-
- I used to love to do
that when I was a kid
with the balloons.
- Yeah. It's like that.
- Yeah.
- And I would break into
the chorus, you know,
"we all live in the yellow
submarine" in the helium voice.
- So you, what is that sound?
Like a Munchkin from Oz?
- Well, I gotta let me see
if I can get, let me see if
I can get my helium back on.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(audience laughing)
You can just do it?
♪ We all live in the yellow submarine ♪
♪ The yellow submarine,
the yellow submarine ♪
(audience cheering)
- And everybody, it still works.
It still works. Yes.
- How are you making your voice happen?
- It's true. I am from Saturn.
- I am amazing. That's a gift.
I don't know if I can do,
well, I definitely can't do it now.
It would sound still manly right now.
(Kelly and Nicolas laughing)
Did you rock it at that talent show?
- Yeah, I won.
I won the contest contest.
- You won.
- Because of the helium voice.
(audience cheering)
- First of all, I have
to say a first grader
that knows "Yellow Submarine",
that's pretty cool.